سماعات راسا تمكن المستخدمه من شم رائحه
البيئه التي يشاهدها عبر نظرات الواقع
الافتراضي هذا ليس ضربا من الخيال بل هي
تقنيه جديده يطورها مهندسون في الصين
لمستخدمي الواقع الافتراضي بهدف تعزيز
المشاهده بحاسه الشم الى جانب الشمع
والنظر والتي يمكن ان يعيشوها اثناء اللعب
هذه التقنيه تعتمد على ضمادات صغيره من
شمع البرافين مملوءه براءه يتم تسخينها
بواسطه قطب كهربائي متصل لاطلاق الرائحه
الملائمه لما يراه المستخدم الباحثون
اقترحوا تجسيد التقنيه عبر وضع مولدات
الروائح اللاسلكيه مباشره تحت انف
المستخدم او عن طريق ارتدائه قناعا للوجه
ويقولون ان التقنيه المستقبليه ستوفر 30
رائحه مختلفه لمن يستخدمها من بينها
القهوه والفطائر والايثانول
[موسيقى]